hello and welcome to this video
Mowrey due to short names people Maori
poor lose Rona that sounds like some
fatal disease or something
I'm sorry if it's something beautiful
with it's up to it anyway so now a big
thing yep
93 is probably the best move there
let's see Maori polluter owner Bishop d3
is a fairly a good off bid line I think
let's see what Maori is playing now
[Music]
taking a very long time Ruki 1 now or
quindi 1 are the main moves rupee one
Queen D one Queen D 1 is more aggressive
rupee one is the idea then I go Queen d8
and we have those two move somehow
instead back and forth Queenie to 27 and
then both both sides go back
rook e1 or ever is possible that move I
don't know and it's a bit odd what's the
point down he wants to go wants to go go
go go f4 maybe
97 yeah maybe 97 I shouldn't think for
ages here probably does not make a huge
difference when I'm what I do
okay so this is interesting I can take
here and play Knight c4 even net c4 is
an odd square but it's an interesting
way to play if it takes on c4 I have
Queen c5 check making use of the
somewhat unconventional queen position
yeah but what exactly is he doing here
if I was hanging 93 maybe that could be
a good move it could be a good move
Knight c3 no okay so this check I guess
that was the idea I have to watch out a
little bit for the oh okay
for f7 but Bishop e6 will be a very good
way to cover everything
yam should be six castling long looks
like I'm fine
b3 is maybe an idea for Bishop III the
app that is definitely an idea the
problem with that could be some queen
deform well it's got c3 then okay but
should be six it's a normal square
covering f7 and c4 and now I'm ready for
long castles I think you should have
gone be three them yeah that I'm not
going to take it's fairly clear so where
do I go then
Queen deform is the most normal move
maybe Knight B 5 then but
yeah just
if he goes Bishop b2 em castling
queenside that b5 is interesting when I
just go to b6 okay yeah
just cover everything now a knight b5
move can be answered also with Queen GG
form then probably Queen f2 yeah okay so
maybe queen g4 isn't that great let's
let's go to d5 okay maybe he can repeat
you know doesn't repeat or try to repeat
I mean white white should objectively
speaking and be very happy with the draw
if he gets it I mean that can never be
good for for white him and now he has
given up d2 so okay is there anything
there threat I can't go bush up d5 but
it doesn't help much
this one does rugby one no please not
this one you see threatening anything
yeah look you one somewhat and maybe
ninety four but I can always give up the
exchange rough if every like it it's not
a big deal so Quincy to maybe just try
to get every pawn I didn't see the smoke
coming that's not good
the first problem is said after after
rook c8 there is ninety form that is
really an issue
[Music]
so if I take it then a six [ __ ] sorry
I'm getting am getting swindled yeah
it's just too bad really
I was completely lost forward it's an
annoying one like here here white can
just resign up objectively speaking so
Queen f3 so what what wins here probably
just be shipped if I if I just prevent
Quincy six nothing happens just I mean
the dead position you can never be after
a couple of moves like here after he
does not play b3 which is kind of and
the only move really night a3 okay and
then b3 but you have to play b3 this is
just terrible after this black must be
clearly better I've got all the
strategic advantages and white has no
attack really and then this is
desperation already giving up d2 yeah
and you should just just win the game
near Bishop d5 you know I mean I saw the
move of course but I wasn't quite sure
if I have a good move after this well
let's say I simply overlooked Queen c6 I
was just thinking whatever I'm it wins
anyway but here okay I'm a six maybe the
engine simply wants to take everything
because I have the Bishop d6 movie
available yeah I mean that means very
convincingly yeah the problem is really
that after after this I'm lost yeah it's
really funny Quincy six is just winning
I come I absolutely didn't say it didn't
then calculate so I have to take this
here and that is still a draw because
here I've got Quincy five quite clearly
so Queen before still works it doesn't
win anymore but winning would be there
simply preventing work at this counter
play now I'm giving up I really
give up our too many points from those
ridiculous positions where the opponent
played terribly and then you just have
to just pick up just convert a simply
winning positional like this is the only
idea really the only idea left and I
even had much more time on the clock
that's pretty awful really okay thanks
for watching